étonnante résurrection maistre de la
trompette sortie d'une longue de
retraite voici cinquante ans
je vais bien mieux depuis que
l'acupuncture m'a guéri et que je la
traîne depuis la jambe le jeune âge tous
les jours et mois les jours je ne joue
pas sur le docteur m'a dit que je ne
pouvais pas faire les deux le même jour
à
les gens nagent pas c'est un monstre de
seine
chaque jour trois heures voire quatre
sur scène et d'un seul trait à son
répertoire
léthel de tina turner de michael jackson
alors les futurs classiques licence b à
ses tubes seront des classes comme
d'ailleurs les syndicats des chansons
des beatles alors nature a beaucoup de
tubes maïs a des idées des associations
avec deux prins wings a dit qu'il
m'écrirait un morceau pour mon prochain
disque
on va voir ce que valent ses
compositions instrumentales car il a
vraiment à côté jazz très fort dans sa
façon de chanter surtout dans les
musulmans
et on va laisse la musique c'est miles
davis musicien hors cadre du bebop rock
les sexagénaires que par l'état civil
son regard ses yeux des toiles un solo
est vraiment solide à gala